cap is one of the first original
American art form
it's an instantly recognizable
combination of movement and sound
it's such a fun thing to say because
people want to see what is that the
bottom I'll show you how you make the
sound that's always a curiosity we make
this an ontology aluminum originally
they were wooden happiest we started in
a five-point now Chinatown in New York
City this slum was one of the city's
first melting pot so percussive dances
that nurtured have seen from African
families Irish digging a British foggy
in the early eighteen hundreds at the
pier American and Irish people who lived
in worked side by side Mari Scorsese
reference origins tap in gaze of New
York rhythms of the dog continent swung
until the kettle with a Myers shindig
some historians believe that inflates
people in America but ending their
bodies receipt for percussion after
drums advance to third for Belgian that
part of history is shared with test and
with improvisation as an essential
element tap is also considered jazz
[Music]
we were considered musicians we consider
our position historical records from the
mid eighteen hundreds describe early tap
as a popular entertainment for blacks
and whites and sellers and dancehall
minstrels performed along with folk
music on violins and and oh those Irish
girls were the pop music at the time and
as poppy that evolved so this fancy
footwork curly toppers like master Juba
even went on to tour Europe by the end
of that century black vintage or shows
made people laugh and over time
tap dancing became associated with
American comedy in the 1900s have
appeared in films even before they had
found a style became very popular in the
nineteen thirties and forties when it
was featured in major Hollywood movies
in Broadway shows as the decades passed
path was displaced by other styles in
popular music and was relegated to
musical theater traditional tap became
an underground expression in the 70s in
New York
staying goldberg and burned the Bufalino
produco to return the old hoofers back
to the stage I think we'll see a control
census city and we knew that the
Broadway cast wasn't quite real thing
we don't go 5 6 7 8 we go mmm mmm like
you know in other words you don't count
you just do it rhythmically the style is
still strong in New York City where
young dancers honored the old huh first
to make music from your feet from like
your ancestors and like your spirit and
for it to come out that way I think it's
quite amazing the most important thing
is when the music isn't there anymore
and this is being substituted maybe at
the arms or the face or not being honest
that's when it becomes a problem it's
all about the music there are old moon
still in force have basic routines the
1920s the shim sham is still danced
worldwide and tap moves on merging with
new immigrants style always felt very
connected with the rhythms that I grew
up with and so I decided to just put
together with my other passions evidence
both Innova samba maracas to all those
rhythms together I mix the American art
form captain with my Brazilian
[Music]
as Cathy Vols dancers who preserve the
old Huffer style are hopeful that it
will continue to capture audiences into
the future something that is so very
intimate and so very rare I find that
it's always fresh and that it's always
new whenever people see tap dancing
they're like wow how can you do that
with your feet it's just always make
people smile
[Music]
[Music]